kyle murray was the first pick in the
2019 draft second pick was
nick bosa and we knew this was coming
chris we could sense it for weeks and as
it turns out matt mario of nbc sports
bay area pointed out over the weekend
that the 49ers decided on nick bose at
the scouting combine and they told
bosu's camp at the time he was going to
be the pick at number two so here's the
thing
we saw three years ago joey bosa hold
out deep into training camp almost
through the entire preseason because
they were fighting over a couple of
factors that are relevant to
the the top contracts every year the
cash flow of the signing bonus whether
or not the guaranteed money is going to
have offset language they fought about
it he held out they got it done
now questions are arising as to whether
or not nick bosal will have a deal done
in time for training camp chris if the
49ers knew in february they wanted this
guy i i'd like to think that they've
accepted the fact that they're going to
have to give him the same kind of
structure his brother got at a minimum
or they're going to have to do without
him during training camp in the
pre-season yeah and that's scary for a
guy who's you know again not played a
lot of football and had injury issues i
certainly would want him there for
training camp and that to me i have no
knowledge of this situation but you know
okay with the joey bosa situation it was
the chargers not basically living up to
what you're supposed to do for top five
picks right and just as far as like some
of the money you're supposed to get the
guaranteed money in the first cash flow
here's what it is it's how quickly they
pay out your signing bonus the chargers
had a way of doing it that allowed the
money to stay in their coffers longer
than other teams did it and the charger
that the chargers came up against an
agent and a player who said no we want a
different structure and they eventually
found a compromise but it's all look
when you draft joey bosa
you don't necessarily know what you're
getting yourself into from that
perspective when you draft his kid
brother three years later and you know
what's happened with joey and he's
represented by the same agents you're on
notice that these are issues so i you
know i'd like to think the 49ers have
have budgeted that reality into their
assessment of bosa otherwise they're
going to end up not having him for
training camp in the preseason just like
the chargers didn't have joey so they
that we'll we'll see maybe it won't be
an issue because the fortuner
there's an injury provision they're
trying to put in the contract something
along those lines because of a guy who's
just had hernia surgery and of course
gets to training or otas and gets hurt
again are they but what can you put in
no you're not going to do a split
contract for the second overall pick in
the draft
right no yeah he's going to get 33 and a
half million fully guaranteed over four
years the only things that really matter
the guaranteed money if he gets cut at
some point the next four years and he
goes somewhere else
do the 49ers get credit dollar for
dollar for what he makes elsewhere that
offset language taking the offset
language out that's one of the things
you can negotiate and from time to time
we see a fight over that and then it's
the cash flow of the signing bonus when
do you get that bonus because there's
value in having money in your account
you can earn interest off of that money
you can do things with that money right
so if the signing bonus is 15 million
you want it all as soon as possible you
don't want five million now five million
six months from now and five million a
year after that you want 15 million
within 30 days if you can get it right
so you can start with the negotiations
that the team wants to get that that's
you know yeah that's that's you're right
that's what they want
sorry yeah and so here's the bottom line
is this the 49ers knew or should have
known what they were getting into with
nick bosa because
there's no reason to think he'll
approach this any differently than his
brother joey did so we'll see how much
they factored that into their planning
their preparation but if there's a hold
out
they can't act surprised right
especially if if the terms of the and
that's all it would be it's cash flow on
the signing bonus or it's guarantee
offsets there isn't much else there
isn't anything else that you can fight
about with those top picks it's also
formulaic at this point you almost don't
even need an agent for that right right
no you don't you don't need an agent
they kind of write themselves so yeah i
mean i'm surprised to hear about this
too i didn't really catch wind of this
until you know what late last night
really when i when i kind of just was
flipping through all kinds of news i
didn't realize this was really a ongoing
thing so
i will be surprised or interested to see
how it all unfolds and um yeah i mean
well i i just i'm shocked that we're at
this point where really with the with
the 49ers there's still plenty of time
yeah right still plenty of time to get
it done before the start of training
camp if they get it done it won't matter
but there's reason if you're a 49ers fan
or just paying attention what's
happening in the nfl to watch that
number two spot because so many of the
guys are currently signed these deals
are easily done caller murray's deal's
done right
these deals are easy to do but but what
happens is you get agents and players
who want to dig in on these issues it's
their opportunity to kind of stand up to
the machine and that's what joey bosa
did and i think nick bose are probably
wired the same way same agents it's just
something to keep an eye on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports